au casse mine c'est un dur coup porté à
la liberté de presse et aussi à la
liberté d'expression des russes ouais
tout à fait une précision à faire
signifier réseau au canada aujourd'hui a
annoncé qu'on allait suspendre
temporairement le travail de ses équipes
sur le terrain en russie pour assurer
leur sécurité après l'adoption de cette
loi mais elle subit si radio canada ne
va pas rapatrier de journal et c'était
cette décision c'est une décision
semblable à celle qu'on a vu d'autres
médias prendre aujourd'hui des médias
internationaux comme la bbc comme cnn ou
comme bloomberg encore une fois après
l'adoption de cette loi par le parlement
russe on a une réaction aujourd'hui sur
twitter du ministre du patrimoine
canadien est pas beau rodriguez qui a
dit trouver la situation est très
inquiétante et qui a dit aussi qu'il
allait tout faire pour protéger les
journalistes canadiens mais bon on parle
de journalistes étrangers aujourd'hui en
russie mais la loi s'appliquera aussi
aux journalistes russes qui faut dire
font leur travail dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles depuis plusieurs
années et là avec la guerre la situation
se détériore on a vu des journaux des
radios indépendantes fermaient leurs
portes et maintenant et même les réseaux
sociaux qui sont vanille comme twitter
et facebook donc ça devient de plus en
plus difficile d'avoir accès à des voies
véritablement indépendante en russie
alors que le conflit s'est ainsi fille
là dessus on peut écouter le témoignage
d'une journaliste française qui a
récemment quitté moscou
pour la première fois manque 15 ça fait
dix ans je travaille en russie
je suis toujours obéir aux règles j'ai
toujours travaillé avec une méditation
j'ai toujours voilà j'ai toujours
respecté les règles religieuses et le
caylar et qu'on travaille dans un pays
qui calque et qu'il ya des règles qui ne
sont pas celles d'un pays démocratique
mais là j'ai senti que clairement le
vent tourner et que on a va être
empêchée de travail
et par ailleurs yasmine le premier
ministre justin trudeau se rendra en
europe la semaine prochaine ouais cette
semaine c'était le marathon des
conférences de presse pour justin
trudeau la semaine prochaine ce serait
le marathon des réunions bilatérales
parce que l'agenda est très très chargé
je vous donne itinéraire claudine
dimanche le premier ministre va
s'envoler vers londres où il va
rencontrer son homologue britannique
boris johnson ainsi que le premier
ministre des pays bas mark loot et en
plus il y aura une audience avec la
reine elizabeth 2 après le royaume-uni
justin trudeau va se rendre en lettonie
en allemagne et en pologne et évidemment
si le conflit en ukraine qui va
monopoliser la majorité des
conversations entre ses dirigeants parce
que les pays occidentaux veulent
continuer de faire front commun contre
la russie là dessus on écoute le premier
ministre justin trudeau
on a vu que la coordination entre les
différents pays les démocraties de
l'occident à en matière de sanctions et
de deux pénalités pour la russie pour
poutine a été extraordinaire la semaine
prochaine je vais pouvoir continuer
cette coordination directement avec nos
alliés
et en terminant je vous précise qu'en
lettonie juste à être douves a rencontré
les soldats canadiens qui sont déployés
en europe de l'est dans le cadre de la
mission de dissuasion de l'otan merci
beaucoup yasmine au revoir au revoir